ya hemos visto el mecanismo de esta
reacción ácido base pero quiero
repasarlo rápidamente lo que hay por
aquí tenemos ácido acético que va a
funcionar como nuestro ácido y por acá
tenemos hidróxido de sodio y el
hidróxido va a funcionar como nuestra
base nuestra base va a tomar el protón
ácido del ácido acético y va a dejar
estos electrones aquí con el oxígeno y
de esa forma obtenemos el unión acetato
y por acá sea o h&m nos lo proponemos lo
que nos queda es h2o entonces estos dos
son los productos ahora también podemos
pensar en la reacción inversa no querer
aquí en lannion acetato también puede
llegar y quedarse con este protón
formando ácido acético y dejando estos
dos electrones con el oxígeno formando o
h - y entonces en la función inversa el
a nyon acetato está funcionando como una
base y él
el agua está funcionando como un ácido
porque está donando un protón ahora qué
tal que nuestro objetivo fuera encontrar
la constante de equilibrio para la
reacción directa no cree cuál es nuestra
constante de equilibrio donde en la
izquierda tenemos los reactivos y en la
derecha tenemos los productos y podemos
encontrar esta constante utilizando
únicamente los valores pk a ver si
conocemos los valores pk a de los dos
ácidos de esta reacción entonces podemos
encontrar muy fácilmente la constante de
equilibrio de esta reacción lo que
necesitamos es el valor pk
del ácido de la izquierda y sabemos que
el ácido de la izquierda es ácido
acético y el ácido acético este protón
de aquí tiene un pecado de
aproximadamente 5 aunque el pk de este
hidrógeno es 5
este lado del lado de la derecha el
ácido es el agua y sabemos que este
protón de aquí tiene un pecado
de aproximadamente 16 y entonces ya
podemos calcular el pk en el p acá
q lo obtenemos tomando el pk a del ácido
de la izquierda o sea 5 - el pk
del ácido de la derecha que es 16 menos
16 y 5 - 16 es igual a menos 11 así es
que tenemos que ver acá q es igual a
menos 11 ahora como pasamos del pk q aca
la constante de equilibrio pues podemos
pasar de pk q aca recordando de química
general que peca q es igual al logaritmo
base de 10 de acá y aquí me falta poner
un menos que es muy importante y aquí
para despejar acá lo primero que hacemos
es pasar el signo menos del otro lado lo
que nos queda es menos
q igual a logaritmo base de 10 de k
ok y ahora como nos vamos a deshacer de
este logaritmo base de 10 pues lo que
tenemos que hacer es tomar 10 y elevarlo
a cada uno de estos lados del igual
aunque si tomamos 10 y lo elevamos al
logaritmo base de 10 de acá el cubo lo
que nos queda es acá
y eso es igual a 10 elevado a la menos
menos pk de cu
acá
entonces tenemos que acá es igual a 10
menos pk
y ahora lo único que nos falta es
sustituir este pk q por el valor que
obtuvimos por acá entonces acá q es
igual a 10 a la menos de kaiku pero te
cae q es igual a menos 11 menos 11 donde
aquí hay que notar que este menor es
este menos de aquí y por supuesto esto
es simplemente 10 a la 11 porque nuestra
acá q es igual a 10 a la 11 y sabemos lo
que esto significa en química general
cierto sabemos que cuando acá es mucho
más grande que uno por ejemplo cuando
tenemos 10 a la 11 entonces en el
equilibrio tenemos muchos más productos
que reactivos y el equilibrio entonces
está hacia la derecha
y tenemos muchos medios de estos
productos ahora si quieres hacer esto
más rápido si sólo quieres saber
rápidamente hacia dónde está el
equilibrio puedes fijarte directamente
en los valores pk
de los ácidos aquí en la izquierda
tenemos 5 y en la derecha tenemos 16
como ya observamos el equilibrio está
hacia la derecha y en la derecha tenemos
el valor pk
más grande de los dos entonces como
podemos observar en este ejemplo el
equilibrio se va hacia donde tenemos un
pk
más alto walker el equilibrio se va
hacia el ácido más débil y esa es la
forma fácil sencilla y rápida de
encontrar hacia dónde se va a ir el
equilibrio simplemente te fijas en los
valores pk
de los ácidos y sabemos que el
equilibrio se va a ir hacia el ácido más
débil que es el que tiene el pk más alto
pero bueno ahora vamos con
ej mckay
tenemos aquí otro mecanismo de reacción
orgánico ácido base la acetona de aquí
funciona como una base y toma uno de
estos protones de h3 y dejando estos
electrones aquí en el oxígeno que por
cierto h3 sidronio y está actuando como
un ácido ahora si protones acetona lo
que te queda es esto de aquí entonces
esto tiene que ser el ácido conjugado de
la acetona
y si al hidronew le quito es un protón
lo que te queda es h2o que es agua así
es que el agua es la base con jugada de
hace tres o más entonces para la
reacción inversa si el agua está
funcionando como una base toma este
protón de aquí y dejando estos
electrones en el oxígeno y de esa forma
obtenemos acetona e hidro neo ahora lo
que queremos es usar los valores pk de
los ácidos para encontrar hacia dónde se
va a ir el equilibrio cayó entonces
necesitamos el valor pk del ácido de la
izquierda o sea del hidrógeno ya eso le
queremos restar el valor pk
del ácido de la derecha ahora el ácido
de la izquierda es libro nio y tiene un
pequeã de aproximadamente menos 2 y el
pk del ácido de la derecha el pk de este
hidrógeno es aproximadamente menos 3
entonces para encontrar el pk eco de la
reacción directa donde estos son los
reactivos y estos son los productos no
creyente k q es igual al pk a del ácido
de la izquierda o sea menos 2 - 2 - este
menos de aquí el pk a del ácido de la
derecha o sea menos 3 - menos 3 - 2 -
menos 3 eso es igual a 1 que el pk cv de
la reacción directa
es más uno ahora de aquí ya sabemos
directamente cómo encontrarla
porque como vimos en el ejemplo pasado
la k es q es igual a 10 a la menos de
acá
ok entonces lo único que nos falta es
tomar este valor de pk cool
y colocarlo por acá aunque peca q lo que
tenemos es que acá q es igual a 10 a la
menos este menos de aquí que no tiene
nada que ver con el pk cv y sustituimos
pk ecu por uno entonces nos queda así 10
a la menos 1 entonces acá es menor que 1
y eso lo que significa es que en el
equilibrio hay más reactivos que
productos el equilibrio se va hacia la
izquierda y tenemos más reactivos que
productos en el equilibrio ahora si
queremos encontrar hacia dónde se va el
equilibrio de la forma más fácil
sencilla y rápida lo único que tenemos
que hacer es fijarnos en los valores pk
de los ácidos y observar cuál de esos
valores pecaa es el más grande que hay
aquí el valor pk a del libro no es menos
2 que es más grande que el menos 3
ya sabemos directamente que el
equilibrio se va hacia la izquierda
porque el equilibrio favorece la
formación de los ácidos más débiles de
los ácidos que tienen un mayor pk
y podría llegar a ser un poquito
truculento porque tenemos aquí dos
signos menos pero menos dos está más
cerca del cero que menos tres entonces
menos dos es un valor de pk
más grande así es que el equilibrio se
va hacia la izquierda hacia el ácido que
tiene el valor de pecado más grande
motte esta es la forma rápida y sencilla
de encontrar hacia dónde se va el
equilibrio